do you think that most MMA fighters have
what it takes to be seals the mental and
physical the brutal weight cut the
brutal fight camp and stepping into a
cage with a train and a league opponent
well this is one of those questions
where you might think there's like a
really definitive answer mm-hmm but
there isn't really some MMA fighters
could definitely be great seals for sure
some of them actually wouldn't stand a
chance as seals and there's a lot of
things that make people quit and not
want to be seals or quit during SEAL
training you know you got the logger
some people don't like the water mm-hmm
some people are uncomfortable in the
water great athletes not good in the
water some people don't like the cold
and they can under stake and take all
kinds of punishment of physical nature
but they don't like the cold some people
don't like Heights and you get to the
top of a 40 or 50 foot cargo net and you
got to climb over that little pole at
the top get to the other side some
people don't like that some people can't
do some simple stuff like memorize mmm
you can't memorize certain facts and
there's a there is a intellectual level
that you have to have some people aren't
situationally aware right so some of
these like for instance you need certain
MMA fighters who are real wild and it's
one of their good characteristics is
that they're oh they're kind of out of
control it helps them do wild things and
fight unexpected things you can't be
like that in the kill house would go and
live fire right you can't have that why
you need to be able to suppress that
some people can't suppress that so what
you'd end up with someone is some of
that's kind of safety issues because
they they're too instinctual and they
can't get those instincts under control
some people might have too much
endurance but not enough strength some
people might have too much strength and
not enough endurance some people are
injury prone right some people are just
injury prone and it's not their fault
many cases but they are and and then you
take so that's sort of the things that
it takes to be in the SEAL Teams that
wood could hold up or trip up somebody
that's just standard MMA fighter
now the same thing is true with seals
that would be MMA fighters right or or
could seal potentially be an MMA fighter
there's been there's been a few seals
that have that have you know that have
fought really well and good fighters and
all that but to make a blanket statement
there's gonna be things that trip people
up and for instance some guys in the
SEAL Teams that they're not the best
athlete their athletic ability is not as
high as it might need to be to be a true
competitor in MMA you know whether
that's they don't have the explosiveness
or they don't have the coordination of
the flexibility there's some thing
that's gonna make them not competitive
and normally those guys I mean sometimes
they might not be the best seals you
know but some of those guys are super
smart and so they're the reason that
they're good seals is cuz they're just
they're just tactically sound and or
they're really good leaders
they're never gonna beat people on the
range shooting cuz they're just not that
coordinated don't have the hand-eye
coordination but they're good seals
anyways but when you put them in a
purely physical competition like MMA I
shouldn't say almost a more physical on
physical competition like MMA they're
not gonna do well and of course
obviously there's a skill set right MMA
fighters trained MMA all the time that's
what they do they trained you Jitsu in
boxing and wrestling in Muay Thai and
judo that's what they do
mmm-hmm and seals also train all the
time but guess what when you're in SEAL
team you're not just training just
fighting right you're training shooting
and you're training tactics in your
training patrolling and land navigation
and parachuting and combat diving and
fast roping and repelling waterborne
operations all this stuff and then on
top of all that stuff which is the stuff
that you actually really need to train
then they put on a level of mixed
martial arts training to make sure that
if you are for whatever reason without a
weapon or if you need to handle somebody
that doesn't have a weapon and so
therefore you might not be in the right
to just shoot them and kill them you
gotta be able to handle yourself so
there's some level of MMA training some
fundamental jujitsu skills some
striking skills some fundamental
wrestling skills that that seals get but
it's not at the level of what a real MMA
fighters going to have so with all that
I think there is a a good percentage of
MMA fighters that would make it through
SEAL training and be good seals and
there's a good number of seals that
would probably make really good solid
MMA fighters if they chose to do that
and focus their lives on it because
there are some common traits with both
of them both of them take hard work both
of them take some level of physical
suffering right grind it both I mean
you've been around when we're running an
MMA camps for people it's a grind yeah
it's a grind it's a day in doubt right
now there's some luxury to that grind
mm-hmm there's some luxury that grind
because when you're in an MMA camp yeah
you worked hard as hell from you know
7:00 in the morning until nine o'clock
doing your strength and conditioning but
then you're gonna go home and you're
gonna get a massage and you're gonna get
you're gonna have some really good food
standing by and you're gonna sit down
you're gonna relax and then at eleven
o'clock you can go back to the gym and
now you're gonna do your your grappling
training and you're gonna train really
hard for an hour maybe an hour and a
half you can do drills you get worn out
again and then then you're gonna go eat
some lunch
you're gonna relax you're gonna go back
home you're gonna lay down maybe take a
little ice bath in his little jacuzzi so
there's some luxury to the mmm agent and
the SEAL Teams there's not that
happening
you're just getting ground down and when
you're going through the basic training
and when you're going through you know
the advanced workup training you're
you're just getting beat down all the
time it's it's a grind
but both of them are a grind and that's
why I think though the work ethic that
comes with a really good seal or a
really good MMA fighter there's a very
strong similarity there and the ability
to take that grinders is what I think
that that intrinsic discipline is what
would make the crossover occur so that
would make a seal into a good MMA
fighter or an MMA fighter into a good
seal or a good Special Operations guy
yeah and there's I mean the crossover
it's ultimately just phases kind of hard
to identify it
overall this
real general because like a MMA fighter
is training sure he's training to be a
better MMA fighter in general but mainly
he's training for an event so he knows
ok it's gonna be this many rounds it's
gonna be this long per round I'm gonna
get this much rest for this round and
I'm training to win that no real
specific so the training is if it's good
training it's gonna best trained him to
function in that event and there's
parameters yeah